vous l'attendiez avec impatience c'est
parti pour le ba-ba express du jour on a
zappé sur france 5 et dans la
quotidienne on est tombé sur une
chroniqueuse atteinte d'un terrible toc
dès qu'elle entend un mot elle est
obligée de le mime et le moc sombre de
nos téléphones terme at il vraiment de
réduire la fatigue que vous nous
demander un dédommagement si on a raté
l'avion à cause d'un contrôle de
sécurité
comment venir à bout des mythes
alimentaires ses couteaux qui est
enroulé quand elle les passe au lof
vaisselle ensuite on a regardé top chef
ça c'est intéressant merci et on sait
pas pourquoi mais hier soir michel
sarran répétait tout ce qu il entendait
globalement se place devant le manoir et
l'assaisonnement sont bien les
assaisonnements solidaire il se passe
des choses pas forcément définissable se
passe des choses mais c'est passé
définissable un corps non raffiné de
répéter tout ce que je dis moi on a
regardé la villa des coeurs brisés et on
n'a rien compris à l'histoire de ce
candidat
beaucoup trop de prénoms aussi adrien
avec sergio adrian des prétendants du
coup pour malentendants bail avec le
dany je sens que la dre sur bfm tv on a
vu un envoyé spécial qui avait pas trop
envie de bosser
puis on va retrouver lionel top dans les
autres france ô le samu ont reçu du
renfort les centres d'appels rognonas
l'on revient ils sont débordés le centre
d'appels et puis sur lci c'était le
débat des candidats de la mairie de
paris avec rachida dati qui apparemment
ces crues dans des chiffres et des
lettres des 145 mille trois cent trente
mille deux cent quarante neuf mille +
16% à 42 % 970 mais quand tu es bon
allez on se quitte avec l'homme aux
lunettes les peluches le loup du monde
le chef à l'oeil rieur et aux lunettes
orange
jean-pierre pouvreau il est faux à fait
logique
voilà on viendra tout à l'heure sur la
sortie il ya bien sûr de anne hidalgo
julie anne hidalgo qui a provoqué un
véritable marasme
la maire de paris sur la mer eau de
paris anne hidalgo par ici par ici la
bonne soupe léché ricaine sur quelle
image voulez revenir la deux voilà deux
c'était quoi comme chef pourquoi parce
que c'était un mauvais épisode pourquoi
est-ce que ça pas très il s'est perdu
s'ils ont perdu six cent mille
téléspectateurs ce soir comment je sais
pas où ils sont partis tout cela mais on
les a eus partir ils sont pas peut-être
le petit ben ali sont les perruques en
fait aucun plein de donner envie c'est
quand même un problème tout au long de
l'émission il y avait le fromage dessert
il y avait l'assiette inverser ça ne
voulait récemment chose quand on
regardait les assiettes s'était pas
savoureux gourmands comme ils disent
donc c'est un mauvais l'or hier aussi il
y avait un truc qui a beaucoup marqué
les gens et les personnes qui ont
regardé moi je vois là je regarde
souvent top chouf au début on croit que
c'est une émission de cuisine accessible
à tous et très vite ya des mots qu'on
comprend pas un je vous dis regardez ya
des mots savola bye bye et fils et on
essayait de les fervents de façon une
cuit dans une âge dit à l'escabèche et
en suisse une sauce matelots son vin
rouge fait venir va
ajoutez du poème de combler quelques
petits pouces de shiso moi j'ai bien la
timide cette année du team qui l'a
jamais le début des cours chocolat blanc
poire à nice moi j'ai jamais essayé
justin lavash comprend pas un mot tu
nous raconter c'est vrai qu'il ya des
trucs vous les avez chez vous c'est ce
truc là sans avoir été oui mais bon là
un moment où on a envie
la première fois de plus on dit ça de
top chef oui c'est pas ça qui est que ça
a perdu alors qu'est-ce que vous
commandez clip sobre parce que pour moi
qui d'habitude avait déserté top chef je
suis revenu et je trouve que c'est
vraiment sympa cette année et j'ai cru
en moi et c'est une petite tendresse
pour eux pour une jeune fille qui
s'appelle juliette jeu mémoire qui a
fait un duo hier avec un adrien cette
halle adrien qui lui l inverse
complètement timide alors qu'elle elle
est hyper exubérante et j'ai bien aimé
ce duo là ça doit être super à l'antenne
dans top chef c'est aussi une candidate
qui a vraiment du mal avec les produits
à mon avis la grande gagnante de cette
saison je suis pas sûr que ce soit une
mais elle essaye quand même magnifique
petits navets
je le vois déjà dans l'assiette celui là
j'ai pris une averse
parce que je le trouve bon on va le
faire on va le mettre au centre on fait
quoi ouais en y repensant très bien
crier comme il vient du mois je
[Musique]
non c'est pas le nave soudure a la
chance d'avoir cerise de groupama
oui c'est vrai mais nenê très amusante
parce qu'en fait elle est tout le temps
à côté de la plaque mais elle est tout
le temps derrière donc ces voix là moi
je le programme est très bien c'est très
dur d'être un bébé ça persiste en ville
c'est papa l'opération ils étaient les
arrêter les spectateurs ils sont pas
sortis de la cus de chez vous et vous
méprisez les gens valérie sauf non mais
c'est fou et toi aussi separate minimaux
600000 vous expliquer germées j'attends
des spécialistes et les à 30,50 très
bien marché sur les cibles mais la chute
la foule pourquoi ça a perdu
le casting n'est pas bon c'est une casse
assez répétitive et dire qu'ils
apportaient ne vous avez lancé sur une
vraie routine une des plantes au palais
reproduit on avait dans les prochains
mois si je peux donner mon analyse
médias excusez moi les chéris je pense
aussi c'est que france 2 à 3 millions 9
le mardi c'est rare zeraoui mercredi est
ce qu'il y avait le match de foot de
lyon psg cartonné oui voilà
après c'est dans max à s'en sortir cible
les ménagères un regarde pas beaucoup de
foot donc forcément avec ça c'est la
palissade
excusez moi oui cassignol casimir
palissade c'est de plus en plus destiné
aux vrais professionnels parce qu'avec
les plats qu'ils préparent ou vous a
donc dire que les vrais professionnels
il le regarde en replay est le reflet
moi j'ai des copines qui adore refaire
les missions mais henry a web ainsi va
le regarder les audiences d'hier
football donc ol psg 5 1 pour le psg 3
millions 9
on avait tf1 émergence alors ça ça
immerge pas du tout ça y est c'est fini
c'est fini il ya beaucoup de choses qui
vont se finir top chef 2 millions 6 donc
c'est pas où fut perdu 600 milles nous
la belle saison c'était à téléfilm sur
arte et je l'avais dit d'après midi que
ça cartonnerait sache on jure que c'est
vrai j'ai dit à mes équipes vous allez
voir un million six et alors ça je
m'attendais pas de sexe et saint jean
baptiste guégan mais l'incroyable destin
donc pas c'est la loi de johnny café 1,1
million il faut savoir aussi je vous dis
et je vous jure que c'est vrai j'ai
regardé ce matin parce que je vous donne
des infos beaucoup d'infos médias
j'oublie ils ont fait plus de 700 mille
téléspectateurs sur les plus de 60 ans
voilà c'est à dire que vraiment le gros
c'est vraiment sur les plus 60 ans
vraiment parce que c'est vrai que
la voix de johnny mais moi je moi je
joue en fait j'ai envie de le regarder
puis finalement je suis resté bien sûr
sur w9 avec enquêtes criminelles et
crime des crimes décline jusqu'à plus
soif les shihri tient justement vous
voulez qu'on vienne sur quoi oui le sarc
langue qu'est ce que c'est que le 5
qu'est ce que c'est que le 5 c'est
rachida dati alors rachid adda tout
qu'est-ce qui se passe et ben moi j'ai
pas vu l'émission
ouais mais ça mérite heures ça a été
repris il ya eu trente mille tweets donc
il est en toc c'est toute la soirée
du coup je les regardais via les réseaux
sociaux et j'ai trouvé ça ouf c'était ce
à tous les débats ont été repris et ça
s'est bien défendu et je trouvais ça
cool
est-ce qu'on a un extrait siouplaît au
régime parce que je n'ai pas là olivier
habib merci ah oui merci
non il est mort oui alors franchement
moi si j'ai trouvé que c'était
totalement abstrait déconnectés de la
vie réelle des parisiens ça s'adresse
d'abord aux parisiens parisien
rien ne m'a intéressé c'est la baston
qui m'a fait rire pascal sont bastonnés
c'est pour ça que j'ai regardé elle
croyait qualité dans l'épreuve de fort
boyard avec la sauvageonne l aller on va
revenir sur eric des 12 coups de midi
va-t-il détrôner paul et oui parce qu'un
nouveau champion dans les 12 coups de
midi qui s'appelle eric rico pour les
intimes qui vous sépare d'eux qu'il
s'agit ont voulu présenter en vidéo
regarde c'est le nouveau phénomène du
midi de tf1 eric un candidat de jean luc
reichmann qui accumule les victoires et
commence à se faire un nom en place
depuis le 21 novembre 2019
voilà cent six émissions que ce candidat
de 45 ans arrivent chaque jour à
conserver sa place dans les 12 coups de
midi
un père de famille et la culture
générale impressionnante à quel enfant
fait référence le droit d'aînesse c'est
l'aîné qui en quelques mois seulement
s'approche dangereusement du record du
champion précédent paul qui avait réussi
à marquer l'histoire du jeu avec 153
participation est pas moins de 691 1522
euros de gains accumulés
s'il avait aussi retenu l'attention des
téléspectateurs c'est aussi parce que ce
jeune homme attachant était atteint
d'une forme d'autisme dont il avait
accepté de parler et que son incroyable
culture avait mis tout le monde d'accord
mais voilà eric qui a aujourd'hui pris
le relais dans le fauteuil de champion
pourrait aussi prendre sa place sur le
podium car aujourd'hui la cagnotte
accumulée par celui qu'on surnomme
fantasque et rixe a dépassé les 561 1313
euros de gains statistiquement eric
pourrait remporter une plus grosse somme
d'argent en moins d'émissions mais
réussira-t-il à battre le record de ce
champion hors norme
affaire à suivre eric je vous le dis il
est très fort un soulier il est très
très fort
vous avez une compile de sa culture moi
je le regarde souvent le mini-camp je
peux et je peux vous dire oui il va
aller très loin oui mais le sort
s'acharne sur le sort à sa tradition
parce qu'il est très fort mais les
détester par le public pour tous les
jours il ya une des tonnes de messages
il sourit jamais mais peas les honneurs
ni d'un sourire on y gagne les gens
allez dégage mythe qui sera agent dérivé
c'est aussi ce que les journées c'est ça
qu'on aime aussi des personnages oui et
on se dit on se dit on a envie de le
voir sortir
et pourtant il est toujours là et les
formules et surtout l'antinomie avec
paul et notre humeur fonctionne très
très bien puisque paul était extrêmement
attachant donc du coup on peut justement
feuilletonner sur cette différence entre
les deux camps par landon timo me
isabelle alors qu'yb antinomie je suis
d'accord mais alors il essaie une
commune comme paul il m'arrive de chuter
sur des questions extrêmement facilement
ce dernier avait une question facile tu
lui mets n'ont pas toi et pas de quoi la
question mais je me suis plus sentie en
douter mais super facile accord mérigeau
pour dit tiens c'est bizarre bas voyais
c'était pas plus bizarre mais j'en
accuse
or six ans alors regardez où vous à
peine contenue le regarder mais je
regardais la question qu je pense que le
terme vient de la culture hébraïque daga
et on parle notamment de lézat eu qui
vendit son droit d'aînesse pour un prêt
de lentilles et zaü oui c'était c'est
pas une échelle linéaire c'est
logarithmique donc ça veut dire que
quand on augmente d'un on multiplie par
30 l'énergie du séisme c'est sa 106e
émission efforts aujourd'hui
effectivement il est là depuis le 21
novembre et je crois que justement vu ce
qui prend sur les réseaux sociaux et ils
ont tort les gens de le critiquer il a
fait venir sa petite fille aujourd'hui à
la télé ce matin
alors hier camille vous savez camille on
adore camille café les 12 coups de midi
qu'on a début vers les douze coups lui
ont fait un gros bisou qui m'envoie un
sms en direct maccabi d'amour elle me
dit coucou s'irrite si je peux me
permettre je fais comme si j'étais
autour de la table fais ce que tu veux
ma camille mais comme situe autour de la
table et tous les téléspectateurs font
de même voilà c'est comme si vous étiez
autour de la table l'odeur en moins je
suis tombé face à eric quand je suis
passé aux douze coups si je pense et je
suis même sûr que ce que les gens
prennent pour de l'arrogance c'est juste
une timidité extrême
il est loin d'être paix dont je suis
toujours en contact avec sa femme et lui
qui me propose toujours de l'aide ce
sont vraiment des gens foncièrement bon
je te fais de gros bisous et ton message
de la dernière fois marc booster et
redonner de la force
merci pour tout camille on t'aime ma
chérie on pense à toi voilà on voyait on
a alors un témoignage de camille café et
bien fait bah voilà bravo chérie tu
continues à te gratter remercie le
problème majeur c'est celui-là des puces
anglais et ça c'est vrai c'est qu'il ait
favorisé les gens le voient comment ils
font dans la production de l'émission
pour favoriser c'est très simple ils
connaissent les lignes de force du
candidat il a été prof
ils connaissent ces points où il est
très fort et lui pose des questions
toujours dans la thématique ça les gens
le voient pas ce qu'il veut le faire
durer donc je ne dis pas que c'est
truqué mais c'est totalement manipulée
et influencée prix là il voit là elle va
tomber les poires vacances salvetois com
allez on va on va venir sur un autre
truc c'est le coup de gueule de marlène
schiappa contre les émissions de mariage
marlène schiappa la mise de l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes est
interviewé par télé loisirs
c'est bizarre
télé loisirs et dont le jardin la
ministre télé loisirs marleix mais les
loisirs ils ont mois son journal et son
droit ou une télé loisirs vous mettez
les loisirs et pourquoi pas tes les
adaptations alors à l'attaqué deuxième
édition des mariages mariée au premier
regard et 4 mariages pour une lune de
miel
marlène schiappa télé loisirs regardez
un peu de mal avec le concept de dévoyer
en fait l'engagement qu'on va prendre
quand on va se marier et de le faire
comme dans paris
je la trouve horrible cette émission en
fait je me dis mais en fait la plus rien
sacré je suis pas croyante du tout un
bon sacré au sens noble du terme il ya
pour moi une forme de manque de respect
d'aller au mariage de quelqu'un pour
dire du mal de la robe de mariée de la
tête du marié et d'égout qui me dérange
parce que je la sens irrespectueux et si
c'est maxime weil ou kelly le carillon
de rabot en tout cas parce que ça fait
je dis pas que je ne dis pas que c'est
lui je dis qu'il bosse là bah oui mais
oui je sais mais si c'est lui c'est fort
si celui-ci est assez drôle ça
désacralise un peu la fonction de
ministre parce qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup
de risques ont donné ça alors c'est moi
je charrier ya un instant mais là je
vais prendre
je vais prendre un petit peu la défense
parce que franchement je charrie mais
sinon alors dans ce cas là quand elle
vient dans tpm peut aussi on peut dire
ouais là là voilà l'appareil serait bien
dans tpm
ça fait même procès c'est une émission
de débat c'est pas mal mais je vois pas
pourquoi le froid aux autres aussi l
envie de parler au plus grand nombre
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que télé
loisirs.fr c'est avec jean marc gisin
fini le site au plus puissant
donc le bloc b donc si elle veut parler
en grand nombre à la raison voilà c'est
jean marc morandini aussi qui est énorme
et télé loisirs mais les bourses et les
plus pertinentes ici pardon parce que là
il dit une grosse ânerie
elle dit je suis pas croyante mais on
dévoie le mariage mais ils se marient
pas l'église qu'elle quel rapport avec
la foi et la croyance
merci à la mairie non mais c'est
vraiment ça n'a rien de savez ce que je
mets sur la copie hs hors sujet mais non
mais non c'est elle qui ont su aller
voir un taureau l'annoncé qu'elle
rebondit à elles rebondi sur le rapport
qui a été fait sur le sexisme en ce
moment devrait beaucoup envie de parler
et c'est son boulot moi j'ai eu pas
d'accord comme jean-michel de dire
qu'elle n'a pas à être là s'est vu par
beaucoup de gens même ici donc c'est
très bien et je suis d'accord sur le
fond parce qu'il ya quand même un
problème dans ces émissions de coriaces
oui oui notamment sur les mariés les
femmes qui se détruisent entre elles à
un mariage
je trouve que c'est donner une mauvaise
image de la femme et je trouve que son
combat est très bien la raison dire ça
voilà dudit virus
c'est de la télé ça vient d'où quand
castaldi faut que tout ça quand on voit
un mariage on critique le buffet la robe
de la mariée
c'est la vie après votre mariage voulait
pas critiquer ah bah oui j'ai toujours
pris mon cadeau de mariage
ah oui oui et alors
et valère que vous avez tous les jours
c'est pas un cadeau c'est un salaire
c'est pour mon travail
ben si je peux y est vraiment votre
travail fait dire je dirais que c'est un
cadeau mais quand elle est sûre balances
ton pastel parle politique quand elle
est interviewée par télé loisirs elle
parle de télé c'est enfin je veux dire
c'est logique on lui pose une question
sur une émission de télé elle répond non
allez merci on vous appelle semaine
prochaine un trait de télé z pour une
sorte de vente bah oui faute grave sur
les chiens puisqu'il faut alors hier
c'est un petit événement sur rtl laurent
gerra j'aime beaucoup à fêter on dirait
que ça 3000e chronique pour l'occasion
rta lui a dédié une émission spéciale
ils ont invité toutes airtel vous êtes
invités non non le céder la place ce que
c'est à la place de laissez-vous tenter
d'accord très bien alors ils calvière
invités notamment alba ventura stéphane
bern
edouard baer ou encore michel drucker
pendant l'émission il a notamment limité
renault qui parle du coronavirus et de
ses conséquences
regardez bonjour renault bonjour
mademoiselle geagea bonjour monsieur
campari ça tu lu dans la presse qu'il y
avait un risque de pénurie d'eau gel
hydroalcoolique
oui on l'a acheté une ou deux pièces
même si entre nous je n'aime pas trop ça
le gel hydroalcoolique surtout l'hydro
oui on attend alors on a voulu se faire
un petit plaisir on s'y fait un top 3
des chroniques de jours laurent gerra
sur rtl alors la première chronique de
laurent gerra sur tel s'est déroulée le
2 janvier 2001 et le plus mémorable pour
moi c'est quand il faisait des
imitations devant les hommes politiques
de faire un top3 il ya d'abord nicolas
sarkozy s'était en 2016 en troisième
position il était candidat à la primaire
de droite ils sont vraiment kiffé
limitations que laurent gerra p2 lui
regardez là c'est vrai qu'on a appris
cet été dans le point et sur rtl que
vous êtes un grand fan de ces jérôme oui
alors je veux le savoir pourquoi que
comment que ça se fait ici fait battre
que j'aime c'est géraud et bah je vais
vous dire j'aime c'est géraud parce que
c'est géraud tafraoui et j'aime aussi
polnareff parce qu'ils donnent tout pour
sa chérie ou et france gagnent parce
qu'elle donne tout pour la musique
eh ben vous voyez mademoiselle jeanne
moi je veux donner tout pour la france
240 pages 18 euros écrit petit
aujourd'hui je fais tout petit je sais
que tu as bien alors j'adore c'est le
seul choix bien meilleur que kung fu à
bas coûts qui vont pas tomber quand ou
quand vous le regardez pas il est
exceptionnel
si vous entendez que labeaume s'est
également donné la raison mais moi et
moi ce que je demande un imitateur c'est
d'être drôle nicolas pour tous je suis
désolé il ronge ira aussi à la chambre
où il est très drôle aussi je suis
désolé il a des auteurs formidable et
s'il est que les textes sont très bons
laurent est très fort aussi mais c'est
vrai que canteloup à ce que j'aime c'est
dans la caricature mais il est très
drôle appelle chacun pense ce qu'il veut
mais si vous allaitez ce jour là mais un
super
deuxième position c'était avec françois
hollande regardez complètement qu'elle
préside en serez-vous mois président de
l'amicale bouliste
je ne participerai pas à des collectes
de fonds pour payer l'apéro après les
parties - président de l'amicale
bouliste je vais arbitrer les parties de
manière indépendante
j'ai mesuré au millimètre près la
distance entre le cochonnet les deux
boules le mieux placé - président de
l'amicale bouliste j'interdirais à
dominique strauss kahn de sortir les
siennes et en première position c'est
face à emmanuel macron regarder laurent
gerra faisait ses imitations quelques
mois avant les présidentielles et la
particularité de ce passage c'est qu'ils
ne se contente pas de faire emmanuel
macron mais il fait aussi brigitte
regardes tu n'as pas vu lé par image
brigitte c'est lequel de paris c'est le
numéro on n'est pas en couverture
en fait alors qu'est ce qu'elle sait
encore alors si c'est pour une véranda
stéphane bern on en a déjà à l'auge non
jeu bon jour si c'est françois hollande
je pourrais parler à emmanuel un jeu
voilà un pêle mêlé fait pas trop perdre
de temps il révise son programme
emmanuel c'est pour toi c'est monsieur
hollande up
qu'est ce qui ne peut encore le gros
seins t il et collants et je dois dire
hier à l'imitateur aux six mois que
j'adore c'est marc antoine le bret il
fait lui aussi des nouvelles voies alors
lui voilà il a réellement ajoute plein
de succès c'est pour moi c'est la sna
rossi voilà il fait partie des trois
stars dans l'imitation enfin l'ariana il
y en a d'autres mais sir et voilà est ce
que vous savez imité juste une personne
vous allez vallée qui imite une personne
oui asie sophie je sais il m'était gros
minet base et shipton sous n'ouvre pas
la porte
oui papa combien c'est isabelle morini
bosc
il a tu sais mieux qui chérit il
s'invite à la médaille
et on fait tourner c'est embêtant mais
n'est sauvé line et nous revient plus
amer